This morning.
Sources tell CNN
that President Biden
is growing frustrated over
how his administration
is handling the message
on the discovery of classified d
at his private office and home.
CNN is also told
that even more searches
of President Biden's
properties are possible.
CNN's M.J.
Lee is at the White House with m
another headache for this admini
So is there a new strategy
in terms of messaging
and what is that strategy?
Well, what we are learning
is that as
this story has consumed
the White House
over the last week,
President Biden himself
has grown frustrated
at what he feels like,
has been a story
that has overshadowed
a positive street for the admini
And meanwhile, in the building
behind me, White House aides
who were many of them in the dar
about this story
until the story really broke las
that their mood is
one of quiet resignation,
that there are sort of a
it is what it is mentality right
as they to wait
like most
everyone else, to see
if more classified documents sur
And what has been really notable
in reporting out this story
is that
even some of the president's clo
allies are sort of starting
to wonder out loud
why the White House
wasn't more forthcoming
about all of this
and about what they have known
and why they weren't more
forthcoming sooner.
Particularly puzzled
by the White House
counsel's office decision
to put out that initial statemen
last week,
but not disclose that they knew
about additional documents.
For example,
former Senator Doug Jones
is somebody that I spoke to
for this story,
and he said that he believes
the White House
has made some unforced errors.
He told me
once you make a statement, once
you have the facts,
you have to be full and complete
They weren't full and complete.
And he says,
gosh, come on,
you all, you've got to do a bett
when things like this happen.
That's exactly what I would say.
He obviously used a slightly dif
word there.
Importantly, though, Jones did
tell me that
he thought the lawyers
had basically handled
everything
appropriately by initially
going quickly
to the National Archives
to tell them
about the discovery of the docum
and answers to the questions
you were posing before
about why the White House
and Biden insiders handled
this as they did
what governed their decisions
and statements?
Well, what we're basically learn
is that ever since
those first batch of classified
documents was discovered
in early November,
the small number of aides
have known
about the existence of the docum
have operated under the basic
rule of don't
share anything publicly
that could jeopardize this inves
And a part of that calculation
clearly comes from Bob Bauer him
This is the personal lawyer
to President Biden,
who has been taking lead on this
You saw that statement from him
over the weekend
when he tried to lay out
how he has been
trying to balance transparency
and not interfering
with an ongoing investigation
as a part of that.
He said, look, I think it's impo
to not be publicly sharing infor
about the investigation as it is
And we have seen this coming
from the president himself.
Remember yesterday
he went to this MLK Day,
a breakfast event,
and he had a private conversatio
I'm told, with Reverend Al Sharp
Sharpton told me
that when they had this
private conversation,
the president didn't
bring up this issue at all.
And when he did
bring up House Republicans,
in that conversation,
it wasn't to talk about
the investigations
that they are promising.
Sharpton said that, said
that it was a talk about
how he wanted to reach out to th
to talk about issues like voting
So sort of a telling exchange
that I think goes to show
how the White House is operating
right now.
M.J.
Lee, thank you so much
for sharing your reporting.
We'll see you soon.
Joining us now to Lou all over N
a White House bureau
chief for The Washington
Post, and CNN legal analyst Jenn
Rogers, former federal prosecuto
Welcome, both of you.
So to Lou,
is there a way now
for the White House
to reverse course,
perhaps get ahead of this story
now that a special counsel
has been appointed? What more ca
Well, first, they have to hope
there are no more
classified documents out there
that will add to this news cycle
which has continued for more tha
now, in part
because it's been a drip,
drip, drip cycle
in which we've seen
new information
coming out, new classified docum
being found in different locatio
So they have to hope that they h
the full review.
It's not yet clear.
They haven't confirmed that.
They have done a full review
of all the various locations
where classified documents might
But if they have done that revie
and once they suggest that revie
it will be incumbent
upon them to put out as much inf
to the public as possible.
Otherwise, you get speculation,
you get investigations,
you get a number of people wonde
person it actually appears.
And so it's going to be incumben
upon the White House,
people close to the president,
his lawyers,
to put out as much information,
as transparent as possible.
Not about
not only about
what's out there, but also about
what what they've found so far,
including the documents
found at the office that he had
the documents
found in his Wilmington home.
It'll be important for them
to say exactly
what happened,
how it happened, who found them,
and why this took place
so that the American people can
be confident that this is not
anything
more than
very often what the president sa
which is a mistake,
something that shouldn't have ha
but something that was
only a sense of sloppiness as op
you know, people
taking things that they shouldn'
have taken on purpose.
Jennifer Rogers, to that point,
it's all he was talking about.
But the news cycle lawyers
care about that in a way,
but they care about other things
What are the legal open
legal questions
that still exist here beyond?
Are there any more documents
Well, we have the special counse
to decide whether there's
any criminal liability here.
I mean, that's the big ticket it
Rob her
is now conducting an investigati
just how those documents
ended up being where they were f
Was there any criminal action he
Was it intentional that they wer
Were they mishandled?
You know, under the statutes
you need intentionality.
So I think from what we've seen
it doesn't look like
there will be criminal charges h
But that's what Rob her job is n
to figure that out
And the question is,
what is Congress doing, Rob?
Her and the Justice Department
are going to have to defend
his investigation.
They can't allow their witnesses
to be interviewed
by congressional committees.
They can't allow this informatio
to leak out into the public real
while it's being criminally look
So they need to protect
their investigation.
And I anticipate
a battle
between the congressional commit
that are getting going
in terms of requesting informati
about this
and the Justice Department and r
special counsel's office
as they conduct their investigat
going forward.
Well, to Lou,
that could just be
one of the many battles
that we could see in Congress
in the coming days and weeks.
The U.S.
government is expected
to hit the debt ceiling
as early as this week, Thursday,
according to the Treasury Depart
You have Kevin McCarthy saying h
to negotiate
the White House isn't budging.
But in terms of what
Kevin McCarthy is ready to negot
he's got a faction
within his own party
that clearly held his own
speakership hostage
What are you hearing about
what they're willing to do
and how far they're willing to g
in holding the debt ceiling host
until they get what they want
Kevin McCarthy won the
speakership in part
by promising these hard line
verses conservatives
within his caucus
that he would take the fight
to the White House
over the debt ceiling that he wo
just approve an increase
in the debt ceiling as we've don
multiple times in the past.
And so this is a collision
course between the White House,
which says they're not going to
that we've already incurred thes
We have to pay the bills that we
And the Republicans who are sayi
that they want to stop the spend
they want to reduce spending,
they want to make cuts
to different programs.
And so
it does appear that
this is a major collision
that is likely to happen
in the next few months in which
the Republicans
are saying that they need to neg
they need spending cuts.
The White House is saying
that they're not
going to negotiate over this
because they've seen what has ha
in the past
where negotiations happened
over the debt ceiling.
And it led to,
you know,
the sort of major problems in th
economy.
And so the White House
and the Republicans
at some point
are going to have to get into a
and work this out.
But right now,
it seems like
they're not feeling the pressure
And the Treasury Department,
I think, is trying to put
some of that pressure on by sayi
we don't have a lot of time.
You guys got to figure out
what you're going to do,
figure out how to get this debt
ceiling raised
so we don't default on our debt
for the first time in U.S. histo
And so it does appear that there
a little bit of a gridlock right
and it will require
some deft handling of this
by President Biden
and by his administration,
because right now
it seems like
the Republicans
are not going to approve anythin
without getting
some sort of spending cuts,
some sort of movement
on the issues that they care abo
And Speaker McCarthy has
his hands tied as well.
So it does appear
that this is going to be
a major collision
at some point in the next few mo
And it's not yet clear
how it's going to work out just
It seems like deja vu,
right, almost every year.
We're at this near collision poi
The question is what you know, a
what point does
it really impact the US economy
and our credit rating to all ove
Jennifer Rogers, thank you